bia um canteiro atravessa julgar o uol e
miguel é miguel monteiro através do
google e irritaram os jogadores saíram
começasse agora pouco triste minuto o
povo não perdoa um povo não perdoa
milhão
outra vez a equipe do meu e eu pude
agora meu é nessa aula e nas alto do
mastro psd miguel monteiro morreu
morro de medo mas teve nascimento
monteiro burro
tá bom
miguel monteiro não saiu quem é este mal
fiquei malfeitas foto perguntar coisas
pois no fim da coisa pública que essa
barba miguel barba branca miguel
monteiro que não era se ficar não é
miguel molina miguel monteiro não pode
rir regravo jogo está muito fora do dano
para a gente fazer um blog com esta
quebra ligamos de 0 1 1 milhão monteiro
e fibra e merece o castigo de miguel
monteiro merece ser castigado pelo ta
morreram miguel monteiro muralha
desculpa à medida que o mundo inteiro
está tudo bem contigo eu acho melhor
começar a jogar miguel de souza tem
comprado até miguel com programador mais
velho fica aqui tudo o que eu não quero
não trate 5 é natal miguel otero
natalinas alto do lado b é natal em
natal de nereida cuidado para com isso
porque para estar em campo com essa
[ __ ] é uma quebra de 9 miguel tem 60
novo miguel tem cura jogo vai ser em 10
02 vai morrer e está insolúvel tá bom
então fugiu com fácil vai morrer eu
errei monteiro não se percebe agora seu
relógio porque todos os miguel monteiro
ela conseguiu me matar em xeque
só pra dar o melhor contra jesus foi o
caso da manteiga
eu não to food é natal é natal desde pdf
bbb caramba né da taxa de 34 mil na
capital e natal
o mago vem caso o seu ataque do pai
letal ela dá um
[Aplausos]
ainda tá aí fui eu não me manter firme e
miguel monteiro
ai ai eu não tenho estágio conceito
miguel quis passar o que se passa hoje
por puro por leo de fita miguel torres
sabe que aquilo que a opinião pessoal de
natal a todos
ele ficou uma graça eu quero também
obrigado casa para o natal a toda a
gente
[Música]